welcome to this video playing purple pop
one okay this is from Poland right I try
to learn this to the skin distinguish
this flag from the Indonesian one okay
we have a Tory attack
Queen Pawn
opening hmm
yeah probably just B6
or can I do something
I can maybe I can harass him a bit on
the B2 Square oops he's taking with the
Knight
hmm well that's uncommon
she takes much more normal looking but
okay I'm just going to set up
a normal position
something like should I go for
a hedgehog or
occupy the center with D5
yeah there's really no reason why I
shouldn't occupy the center
head shock is with D6 but it's pretty
yeah that's pretty
pretty conservative concerning that he's
just not doing anything in the center
so I can play D5 why not
okay Knight here hmm
yeah so E5 he can take on on C6
and he always has a knight F5 hmm
Queen C7 this bishop G3 yeah that's not
leading to anything so maybe this one
now I have E5 ready and Bishop D3 I have
Knight C5 here so this just runs into
Knight C5
and this is not a very good peace
placement anyway
so E5 or yeah let's let's push E5
okay well the Knight is just not well
placed on G3
so uh kinda surprised
um yeah I don't want to take what I do
want is maybe I can I can get in
something like E4 Knight D4 Knight E5
so that I can jump to D3
this also possibly
G6 H5 this this kind of
this kind of business
or maybe bishop G4 then taking then E4
then 95 this is actually nice to make
sure that after E4 he does not have
Knight D4
E4 is also good oh that's some spoiled
for Choice here
I'm not sure it's all good
now I'm getting to D3 without him having
a knight on D4 that's not the end of the
world for white this Knight on D3 but
it's certainly nothing that white will
particularly like
um directly no I can I can first
improve a bit
um
yeah that's not not doing much for white
but I cannot really
do something great here
and this looks nice but it's not doing
that much
yeah Queen B6 trying to provoke a
weakness Maybe
white also can do Knight e2c1 or Knight
E2 F4
which probably
is just okay
hmm
Queen B2 this Rook D3 yeah that's not
good
and Knight B2 I can take Knight B2
Knight B2 Rook B1 Knight C4
Rook B6 proof well that's rather
complicated
um if I take here Knight C4 Rook b692
go back to I can I cannot really
it's a bit difficult I've spent lots of
time he spent no time
I mean okay
after doing any commentary but still
so yeah takes B6 I take D2
not sure about this is probably not too
bad for white
yeah that's a weird move why doesn't he
take on B6
I don't know
foreign
it's not really trying to play any good
moves just playing quick moves
Rook C4 I can take F5
yeah let's let's just keep the material
for now covering
bl7 and covering E4 for the for the
moment
yeah he's
yeah trying to to use this pin now time
warning okay
that's not very convenient so I'm giving
some material back probably with Knight
B7
I'm one Pawn up
I was I wasn't really worried about Rook
F1 I was more thinking about Rook D1 but
I have Knight B7 now to
to return one pawn and still remain with
a good structure
and maybe I have Knight C4 as well
yeah I don't mind the trade him
yeah I've kept my Pawn somehow
and I'm going to get Knights exchange so
it's still not easy you can take Rook C1
take the C file
it's not um not a super easy win with a
little time but he's now catching up on
the clock which is good news
it's very typical they play super quick
moves that ruin the position and then
they start to think when they're much
much worse
um yeah it's got the C file
yeah it's not that easy technically
speaking
5f4 or something
checking here if I have a form chat not
really
it's not really great
I want to go to G3 if possible
giving me this active Queen position so
that E3 becomes
becomes a weakness
check
so
um
yeah I like the time to calculate this I
only have eight seconds how did that
happen check
check
yeah
s on time but he forfeited on time oh
I'm sorry for that I'm so sorry
yeah okay what can you do
I'm just
winning around here but with this little
time I didn't manage
didn't manage to to really put it away
so yeah it was a bit bit of a tricky
position still
and some things I was just very
mysterious after Rook B1 uh Knight C4
why doesn't he take on B6 which is just
kind of what else
something like that is definitely uh
never worse for white I mean it's
probably better here
my knight hangs I have to go here and I
thought okay I really don't have
something great anyway so I went for
this but here white is just okay
I mean something like like this
let's say is if we do a simple count as
someone Pawn for white
he's got a bad Pawn structure but still
it's a pawn so
instead he went Queen C1 where now I'm
just a pawn up you it's not it's not as
as we saw so so trivial all of it
but um
don't really want a deep analysis here
just I just want to check
yeah here when I read he when I return
the pawn
it's probably about okay
and this is not so easy it looks okay I
mean I'm have this extra Pawn but he's
got the only open file and it's not so
clear how I how I should play this maybe
Rook d87 trying to to get one Rook off
I really don't know
that's not an easy easy position really
I was aiming for for this idea here with
Queen G3 which is a good practical idea
probably but
it's not not clear cut in in any way
I thought it should be should be in good
shape but okay I had a little time
but the comp is not finding an instant
win I mean queen F4 seems to be a big
Edge but check
Nothing winning Rook C Aid wins
oh yeah this is not not exactly
difficult Rook C8
and especially considering that I had
nine seconds I really should do that
check check this only leads to this uh
yes this is this end game which is still
a draw
I mean why this passive here but still
it's a draw but how I could win on time
with five against 18 is not quite clear
to me that uh somehow I managed okay
thanks for watching